in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Warren and hope are with us hey guys how
are you
we're good you're here to do your
debt-free scream where do you live
Nashville Tennessee your neighbors yeah
right here from Nashville we don't get
many locals in here and I need to do the
screen that's awesome good well right
here in the neighborhoods how much debt
did you pay off we paid off a hundred
and one thousand four hundred and eighty
three dollars and 56 cents I love it
that's a lot how long did that take 25
months good for you making what kind of
money during that time well Dave we
started out making eighty-five thousand
five hundred and ended at ninety six
thousand cool what do y'all do for a
living I'm a membership director for the
YMCA here in Middle Tennessee and I work
for Vanderbilt at the School of Nursing
oh very cool
good for you guys excellent excellent so
what kind of debt was the hundred and
one thousand pretty much all student
loan debt
we had about nineteen hundred dollars
from our wedding rings and Warren's car
lots of student loans okay so you wake
up twenty five months ago and you said
this is not okay what happened tell me
your story well we had just gotten
married oh okay I just knew that I did
not want to go through our marriage or
started out being in debt so I told hope
I said you know what we've got to get on
the same page and start working through
this debt and I knew of you and I used
to listen to a sports radio show and you
would come on after it so I would
continue listening to the radio show and
I listened to you and I said hope we got
to get in tune with this so so um I kind
of checked out the Total Money Makeover
online and it was like seven day free
trial or whatever and I was like well
I'm the queen of canceling the free
trials so I'm gonna cancel this I just
want to see what it's about and I forgot
about it
you know and you tell God your plans and
he laughs at you so so he was like the
book got delivered to our front door and
and I was like okay well I guess well
and our journey started we ran the book
and we started making a plan and and
created our budget and Wow the rest is
history
very cool so it was really a joint
effort in that not one of you drugged
the other one it was kind of you mean to
do this yeah we need to do it okay let's
do it well and there's kind of a back
and forth and then there there lands the
book and okay that becomes our guide
that's it yeah and then you guys get to
be the heroes congratulations man that's
so neat that's a lot of yeah I mean just
we paid a hundred and one thousand
dollars to meet the love of our life
yeah we decided that we just had to get
on a budget and stick to it and have fun
with it and work together okay so I mean
you you you lived on nothing you really
did scorched earth there you happy your
make it 90 and you paid off fifty a year
we lived on about twenty-four
twenty-five thousand a year yeah yeah I
mean I mean nothing means it right and
beans and rice you know the the New Age
rice and beans I think is ramen noodles
there you go I want to that one we even
created our own what well hope likes to
call guts that we can make burritos
tacos stuffed peppers you know you just
put it in everything I'm kind of tired
of it all yeah I'll bet ready to go out
to a nice restaurant yeah well you've
earned it you've earned it you make 96
thousand dollars a year and you have no
dad so when are you gonna go to dinner
with your own money we have a saying
around the no house we say that's so
Dave Ramsey that's so des need to
Warren's job they're a couple people who
they felt L warned um they would ask
themself yeah
what would warn it hope dude there you
go that's it that's it what would they
do cuz they're hardcore people did make
fun of you then
Oh a little bit but but we had a lot of
support and from family co-workers or
church family so so people were proud of
you they are yeah that's
they should be you ought to be proud of
yourselves how's it feel
yeah awesome it was really good and I do
want to say that we tithe the entire
time we thought that was really
important ten percent and about two
months into it Warren was about to lose
his job and we were celebrating my
grandparents 60th wedding anniversary
and we went to their church and
something was just telling me well the
Holy Spirit we was just telling me you
you have to tithe 10% this month because
I was like really struggling with doing
that and I wrote the check and he got a
job like two days later I just really
think that you know Trust is so
important in faith trust and faith and
that shows up in your checkbook it's in
a tangible way you did the right thing
that's awesome yeah that is very cool
well congratulations so what do you tell
people when they hear you paid off one
hundred and one thousand and they say
how did you do that what are the keys to
getting out of debt being on the same
page working as a team doing the budget
you got to do them you gotta just like
you say yeah every dollars got to have a
name and we got to tell it where to go
and make it work for you pay yourself
you know and just kind of we just did it
as a team we work together we created
our plan each month and we had fun in
the process
you know she made it a game she wanted
to see how much more could we pay off
each month save year-to-year didn't
spend any money himself like the first
month that we did this i budgeted like
$200 for our spending it was crazy and
he spent like I think it was $8.00 so
now so now I'm a lot of $25.00 a month
now
oh now yeah it's way up you got you got
a four fold right yeah you want my mom
would give us like gift cards McDonald's
and subway and stuff just because she
felt bad for Warren when we got
Christmas money from family they would
say no Warren don't let Hope have this
but yeah you know being the team team
member I am I say you know
vermin of the team we're gonna we're
gonna put it toward the dead hope what
was the hardest part of this for you I
mean you you really have I mean we're
joking around here but you've lived on
nothing I think it's just not spending
money and we're very social people you
know so we like to hang out with people
and stuff and I think it was just like
staying home and not going out to eat
with everybody after church on Sunday
things like that our family is all in
Kentucky and so we travel to see them a
lot so just you know cutting down on
those trips not being able to see them
as much so that was definitely the
hardest part but like Warren said we
really tried to make it a game so I'm
like very competitive nerd I really just
wanted to see how much can we pay off
and then we would do things like we just
make it fun um we went my mom got is
this chick-fil-a calendar that has this
cool card on the back and you get a free
entree each month so we who warned hates
grocery shopping so we was Jo we would
go to all the that's tip number one shop
at all because the prices are so much
better but it's right down the road from
chick-fil-a and we would go to
chick-fil-a and we would get the entree
and get like another sandwich and split
fries and a coke that's that's key -
could you get really free refills you
turn it into it you turn into a game
that's awesome she got me out to help
with the groceries yeah that's the trick
you got arrived into it with a half a
chick-fil-a meal that's it you guys are
awesome well congratulations thank very
proud of you very pretty you know you
can do anything now if you can do this
you can do anything that's right turn
the next next big hurdle into a game and
have at it yeah you guys are awesome
alright Warren and hope from Nashville
101 thousand dollars paid off in 25
months making eighty five to ninety six
living on nothing did it in two years
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I love it that is awesome way to go you
guys
way to go absolutely incredible
Oh